[Music]
during today's session we're gonna talk
a little bit about the business drivers
of why Discover Financial chose to
pursue a virtual assistant we used to
mitigate negative perception of AI and
enterprises and the process discover
developed for building and deploying
virtual agents as well as ideas of
metrics that should be captured to
ensure virtual assistants continue to be
adding value to your organization so a
little bit about discover discover was
actually my first customer I worked with
when I came to Google about fourteen
months ago and I walked into the meeting
after they had done a bake-off for NLP
it's tools to help with a virtual
assistant and I walked in and they
seemed really smart and I was like oh my
gosh like if all customers are this easy
or this smart my whole job is going to
be like the easiest job in the world
and it turns out that wasn't entirely
true but working with Discover has been
really fantastic because they have they
use really intentional decisions and
careful processes for like enabling
technology that enhances the customer
experience across their enterprise as
well as with their external customers
and they are also pushing boundaries in
in stretching the capabilities of what
the virtual assistant and dialogue flow
can do with innovation innovative
approaches to testing metrics and
deploying the agents across the
enterprise so I'd like to welcome up
price to talk about it he's a business a
senior business manager for digital
automation thanks Rachel so as she said
I'm price fetter I lead automation and
our digital servicing channels here at
discover quick obligatory legal
disclaimer there we go so a lot of
people think of discover is mainly just
a credit card company but we also offer
a slew of banking products checking
savings savings accounts too personal
with student loans but really our goal
is
to help people achieve a brighter
financially future and really that means
that we put the customer first in
everything we do from the processes we
have in-house to the products we deliver
to our customers it's a little bit more
about us
were available in 190 plus countries we
have 15 Network partners around the
globe and China India Japan Africa South
America just a name few but we have over
a hundred million touch points our
interactions with our customers to
service their accounts annually which
means and that's supported by over 8,000
of our customer service experts in the
digital space specifically we've had 12
years of experience with messaging with
our customer service experts and as that
channel was matured we've seen explosive
growth and just over the past over the
next five years we're expecting 60
percent year-over-year growth in those
digital channels so really we're looking
for ways to support that and so we came
to the conclusion that we needed a
virtual assistant but we don't think of
it as a cost-cutting measure per se but
more of a way to deliver a service that
our customers really are looking for our
customers really want something that
they can get answers to their questions
as fast and easy as evenly as possible
with every brand not only discover so
that was the original I guess driver
behind why we decided to go with a
virtual assistant but not only that
we're seeing some really great
I guess lifts with our agents they're
able to handle the more emotive complex
conversations now which enables us to or
enables them to really have a better
interaction and touch point with our
customers and then finally because of
this we're able to kind of deliver new
capabilities for the channel things that
we were
originally thinking about how did we get
there
many people within our enterprise have a
perception of AI you know Holly
you can thank Hollywood for terminator
for Robocop for how nine thousand you
can thank PR disasters from for Twitter
bots and stuff and that's really what
people think about when a eye comes to
comes to mind what they don't think
about is what they interact with on a
day-to-day basis that is AI spam filters
voice assistants Maps you know and so we
really had to ground them and what was
reality versus what they perceived a eye
to be and we also had to make them more
comfortable that we were actually
putting the customer first and thinking
about how we introduced AI to to
discovered so for example we its
disclosed if you will that our customer
is interacting with the virtual
assistant every time and then if if we
do end up having to transfer that
conversation over to a customer service
expert we tell them as well so it's a
transparent experience for our customers
when when we roll out or rolled out the
virtual assistant though we had to
really think about how this would affect
our customers and we also had to think
about the best way to define value for
each of the intents or inquiry types so
we looked at the volume and our channels
for instance to understand what the the
most high-traffic
intents were we once those were defined
we went and define kind of a happy path
for the customer looked at areas where
that conversation might break and really
figure out the best way to communicate
with our customers
for each of these intents or inquiry
types once once you know we were able to
deploy or develop and deploy an intent
we still have to make sure that we're
legally compliant we're you know
checking all the boxes with risk etc but
then once we launch we we don't just
leave it and walk away where we're in
the channel constantly monitoring our
customers interactions with our virtual
assistant and making sure if there's
better ways to communicate with the
customers better ways to improve the
kind of flow of the conversation ways to
improve our models by introducing new
train phrases etc and then oh and now
I'm going to show you a quick demo of
just a sample interaction with what
we've been able to develop over the past
year it's just going to show a sample
interaction with the customer on our
website and then moving to the mobile
device while maintaining that same
conversation across channels and then
transferring over to an agent when the
conversation gets a little more complex
[Music]
[Music]
so you know so we don't build in a delay
or anything any fake typing bubbles for
the interaction with our virtual
assistant that's really to show that
we're not trying to deceive or you know
make sure our customers aware that
they're actually interacting with a
virtual assistant with that I'm gonna
turn it over to John to kind of talk
about how we utilize dialog flow and
what we've built on top of it thanks
grace everyone John Coyne I'm a software
engineer at discover as Rachel mentioned
early last year we performed a thorough
evaluation of different LP providers or
we ultimately decided to go with dialog
field to implement our virtual assistant
we then spent the remainder of the year
building out the platform and the
necessary automated processes to deploy
our system so today I'm going to cover
some of the building blocks that you can
use and some of the performance
measurement tools to constantly build
and deploy a virtual assistant so during
our evaluation period our primary goal
was to measure the performance of intent
detection so what's an intent quite
simply a user question or intention it
really it's the first and the key step
to building a virtual assistant if you
break down a virtual assistant into two
high level components its detecting what
the user wants and helping them fulfill
that intent or what's known as in
fulfillment now we actually have a
separate team that manages more of the
fulfillment side of things and that's
more procedural nature you know where
you're basically going out to fetch user
data or performing an action on
half of the user where the intent
detection side is where more of the AI
machine learning comes into play and
that's what my team focuses on and
that's gonna be really the theme around
my talk today so for those who aren't
familiar with dialog flow let me explain
some of the basics a dialog flow agent
is a virtual representation of your
logic representation of a virtual
assistant to your agent you add a number
of intense and then to each intent you
add a set of training phrases the
training phrases are then basically used
to customize your model it's really
built on top of Google's underlying and
allyou models they're built from years
of experience so your training phrases
really should include examples of how a
customer might phrase a specific
question for example here I have a tank
called available credit where a
customer's asking their tenth would be
what inquiring about their available
credit to spend is what it is
and you can get some of this data from
actual customer messages that you would
either sanitize or economize as part of
your input to this one of the important
features of dialogue foe that we like
this was something called confidence
essentially which with each intent
detection that dialogue flow performs it
returns you back a score to indicate how
confident was and then intended just
detected and this was really important
to us to be able to make intelligent
decisions about our virtual assistant
replies dialogue flow allows you to set
a minimum threshold that if this
confidence score does not meet that
threshold they can do one of two things
return you back a fallback intent or no
intent at all
a fallback intent could be something
just like a clarifying statement asking
the user to reword their question but
this is something that we decided not to
implement because really it was more
important for us to be able to get it
right and try to automate it and if you
actually noticed here's something that
we do is we set our minimum threshold
extremely low just 10% now it doesn't
mean that we're actually sending the
replies back to users and all the
scenarios but what we're doing is we're
collecting data around on the intent
detection process so we can make more
informed decisions about how we want to
really send our replies back and I'll
touch that on this a little bit more
later
so the testing process that we
established during our evaluation period
is something that we've actually built
into our daily process as we're adding
new intents and we're updating existing
ones to start off with you get to scour
for real data from customers whether it
be from existing IVR channel chat or it
could even be inbound email Channel but
you might really have to spend some time
to actually get good labeled data so
here's a customer message and here's
what intent you expect to get back and
something to notice you want to make
sure that your training data that you
use for the training phases is separate
from your testing data because you don't
want your results become biased so when
you have your labeled data with a
message in an intent you can send it
through the dialog flows API to detect
the intent you get back a name of an
intent along with a confidence score and
then from there you compare the detected
and expected intent you can generate a
set of core metrics now we do this on a
per intent basis essentially for each
intent that we have defined we go
through and calculate each one of these
metrics so giving a couple examples
if a customer said why is my credit
showing as zero dollars if we detected
this as the intent available credit and
we expected to get double credit then
while we're calculating available credit
metrics we consider this a true positive
however if we're calculating the metrics
for another intent called payment
posting we consider this a true negative
because we did not expect to get content
payment posting and we did not get back
through content in a posting and that's
the definition of what is your negative
is for the purposes of our individual
intent metrics this is not as important
but we still notate it the true negative
bit is let's say for another message of
customer said it shows my payment posted
but I have no credit available just
wondering it when it will be available
if dialogue flow detected this as
payment posting but we expect it to get
the intent available credit and while
we're calculating available credit
metrics we consider this a false and I
gave the conversely for payment posting
we consider this a false positive so
once we're done with this process we
then calculate a set of more advanced
metrics that can give us some better
insights
first one is known as precision or
positive predictive value we can use
this to determine if we have problems
with false positive
and really it's defined as the total
number of tests where a specific intent
was detected
for example available credit what
percentage of those were correct
another intent known as recall or
sensitivity or true positive rate can be
defined as the total number of tests
where a specific intent was expected for
example available credit what percentage
of those were detected correctly as
available credit and this will let us
know if our intent is to narrowly
defined missing messages that it's
intended to pick up so using our simple
data set from the previous slide we
would end up with a precision of 100%
but a recall of only 50% for available
credit so really these two metrics are
complementary for the purposes of
measuring performance you know precision
can be 100 percent with only one true
positive if we had no false positives
but if recall is low for the same intent
there really means it's missing almost
all messages entirely it doesn't really
provide much value recently we've
actually started calculating a new
metric called f1 score which is the
harmonic average of both precision and
recall as a number of intents has grown
and became more cumbersome to look at so
many different metrics so the f1 score
provides a single single number that we
can look at to look at our intent
performance so comparing a couple
intents seems easy enough right the lab
is when you scale up to 10 50 100 and
tenths
this is where a tool known as a
confusion matrix can really come in
handy using the output data from our
test process we can generate essentially
a heat map of the intent detection
performance we mapped the detected
intent along the rows and the expected
intent in the columns and in each cell
is the percentage of times where those
intents meet so if you see the dark line
from the top left tag on down the middle
to the bottom right this is where the
detected and the expected intense match
and this is what we want to see
basically the lighter shade means less
confusion or less times they meet and
the darker shade is we're going to see
in the middle so anytime we see a darker
shade outside of that middle is where we
have areas of opportunity so for example
here I've highlighted an intent called
unrecognized transaction has been
detected 19% of the time and we really
expect to get pending transaction so
what can we do when we see this
there's a few different things one of
them is we need to go down into the
training phrases for each of these
intents look for similarities that we
can try to eliminate the second thing
that we could try to do is actually just
the confidence threshold perhaps if we
increased it they're gonna be less false
positives for unrecognized transaction
lastly you might just need to combine
these two intents into a single intent
and I build the conversation flows out
to direct users on the right path so now
I'll touch a little bit on a dialogue
flow agents that we use similar to
common software engineering practices
where you have different development
tests you know production environments
we do a similar structure for our
dialogue flow agents and our development
and training environment is where all of
our updates happen manual either via the
dialogue flow console or via some
processes that we built out the API
calls that they provide to update the
train phrases when we're ready to
promote to the next environment we can
execute a deployment pipeline that
exports from development to our staging
environment here we can perform
acceptance testing and run some
aggression tests for rate confident
enough to deploy to production where we
actually extract out the entire
configuration into an artifact that we
that we sent into artifact repository
and we executed another pipeline to
deploy that into our production
environment there's never any manual
updates happening into production it's
all through processes that are automated
being a finance institution we're highly
regulated on being having auditable
processes that are repeatable is really
important so expanding a little bit upon
the pipeline I just talked about this is
something that our business product
owners can initiate and manage
themselves it runs through all the tests
in the metric generation that I've
talked about and it compares the metrics
against the prior version so ya can
actually see where things have improved
or may you may have introduced some
issues and then it actually generates a
summary report for you that will
highlight the changes for you instead of
having to go search for them so while
you know engineering team has built out
this process it's something that a
business or product owner can be easily
execute and interpret the results
themselves so now I'd like to give a
quick demo of this process
and full disclosure here this is a
pre-recorded demo I wanted to be risk
averse and also cut out a couple minutes
from the middle so right now I'm logged
into the dialog flow web console here
updating our training agent and I'm
editing the intent available credit
here's the training free section so what
I'm actually gonna do here is the phrase
that we saw early my example that got
detected as payment posting even though
I'm going against my own advice I'm
gonna go ahead and add this as a
training phrase knowing that it's in a
testing set and I should see performance
improvement I would hope right so let's
go ahead and add that we'll save the
changes I'm gonna hop over to another
tab here this is actually an internal
web tool that we've built out for a
business product owners to help manage
our virtual assistant they can do a
number of things from this from this
tool and one of them is actually run
that deployment pipeline
oops so here we're gonna go ahead and
select the source as the training agent
and we're gonna deploy that to our
staging agent and once we kick off the
deployment here we're get a message
saying the our execute our job has
started I'm gonna hop over to our
continuous integration server and just
go ahead and explain some of the steps
that are going on here so one of the
first things that we do is we export the
source agent dialog flow provides an API
we can actually extract the entire
configuration into a zip so we do that
for the source and the target and then
we perform some validation tests this is
mostly just to look at the content
dialog provides a capability to set up
like a custom payload for your responses
that we use like dynamic slots for you
know user data so we're just doing some
skiing the validation air to make sure
it's well-formed the next thing that we
do is actually generate a difference
report so basically any intents that
were added anything we're training
phrases were updated or any content
that's changed we're gonna list out all
the changes that have happened sometimes
if there's multiple people that are
updating the agent we want to make sure
that we list out all the changes and we
have that you know documented next thing
we do is think about this like unit
tests and software engineering certain
phrases we want to make sure that are
always detected as specific intents so
we make sure that those those paths if
not gonna fail the deployment next thing
that we do is run through all the tests
and metrics that I've talked about and
then we
actually perform a threshold validation
making sure that our metrics at least
made a minimum standard or us will fail
the deployment so after that's done we
get a slack notification to our team
channel here our product owners can go
ahead and check out the results we send
a link that they can go ahead and
download and we actually require an
approval you know somebody obviously we
want them to check the results out first
before they approve the actual
deployment so here I'm gonna go download
our difference report and hopefully that
we see just one chain one change was
made and here we can see intent changed
available credit and here's the training
phase that I added so that's good now
we'll go into our test evidence floor
here we can see there's a confusion
matrix there's the test metrics and then
the raw test results every single
message in what it was detected as if we
want to investigate it not that we do it
every time but it's there so I may go
ahead and download the summary report
and here we can see ok the precision
increased for payment posting that's
good less less false positives there it
looks like the precision decreased for a
couple of other intents that I wasn't
expecting the recall did go up for
available credit so that's good and true
true positives went up there but the
recall actually went down for a number
of other intents so it's pretty
interesting really kind of what this
highlights is you know machine learning
AI is not really an exact science you
know you can't always expect you know
something's going to work out the way it
is and just having a process like this
that we can automate really helps us to
enable to do this at scale
all right so now that we've deployed to
production how do we monitor our
performance and continue to improve it
so within our whip internal web tool
we've actually built a process where we
can view the messages and what they were
detected is we can go ahead and annotate
those as either correct or incorrect and
if they were wrong what was the right
intent this allows us to do a couple
different things one of them is actually
generate the performance metrics of our
real production model right it's one
thing to be able to look at in a test
environment saying okay this is how we
should do but it's much more valuable to
see how you're actually doing in
production the second thing that that we
do is actually create an automated
process where it can export some of
these messages into our test environment
let's say you know messages was detected
at a very low confidence special but it
was right that was the correct intent we
can go ahead and try to add that to our
development environment to see how it
improves the performance lastly we can
generate something that's known as an
ROC curve here we plot the false
positive rate along the x-axis the true
positive rate along the y-axis for
varying confidence thresholds so for
example here I've highlighted at an 80%
confidence threshold minimum threshold I
can expect to get about a three point
nine percent false positive rate and a
four eighty two point three percent true
positive rate so circling back to my
previous slide and confidence but if we
had our minimum threshold say eighty
percent we wouldn't be able to collect
any of this data to the right so this by
by setting our confidence low collecting
the data we can analyze it and make a
more informed decision about how we want
to set our confidence thresholds
otherwise you're just taking a guess so
talking a little bit about how we
utilize this data in production our high
level processes basically when we
receive an incoming messages we first go
to a dialogue flow detect the intent and
get back a confidence score part of our
business logic is then one looking to
see if we have that intent enabled and
two if it meets the minimum confidence
threshold we enable the company
stressful to be set on a per intent
basis if one's not set we use a global
default so now you might be asking why
would you have an intent enable or
disable I didn't have it in your
dialogue flow agent and there's a number
different reasons for this one of them
is you know if you have something
deployed and you see an issue with it
being able to quickly turn it off is you
know something that is useful to us you
could say
why not just delete the intent of
dialogue flow but as we've seen making
model making updates to your model can
have unintended consequences second
thing that allows us to do is actually
deploy new intents to smaller number of
channels we can actually control these
settings at a per channel basis so we
have a channel only we're only employees
can access so sometimes we'll beta test
a new intent in a channel where only
employees will see it before rolling it
out to them to the broader public and
the last thing that we can actually do
is define intents that were either not
ready to fulfill yet or we just don't
have an entire to fulfill you know this
can deflect away from you know giving
incorrect responses one example might be
for an intent increasing are increasing
the users credit limit let's say that
somebody comes in and we see them ask
I want to decrease my credit limit I
maybe this isn't a common request so if
this was detected as the increased
credit limit intent you know it's gonna
end up with a bad user experience so by
quickly defining a new intent to
decrease credit limit we can go ahead
and get that detected but then routed to
an agent to handle it so it has a better
customer experience and with that I'll
go ahead and turn over the place they're
bad things up here so yeah just some of
our key takeaway some of our learnings
over the past year when we started this
process that was really we needed to
tackle kind of the preconceived notions
that people think of when a eye is
brought brought to bear
so tackle us head-on bring examples of
what AI is in their everyday lives and
that'll really help people understand
that it's not just you know monster
under the bed kind of thing when we
defined our processes for taking an
intent and really defining the customer
value the value for us as a business and
all the way through production into
post-production and you know being able
to train and improve that experience
post-launch we really didn't reinvent
the wheel there we leaned on existing
processes we use metrics from other
channels
that when we were talking about the
virtual assistant it wasn't confusing
everybody in the room big for us be
customer focused we in John mentioned
this earlier were it able to introduce
new intents that were not necessarily
fulfilling to get the customer to
customer service expert as fast as
possible and get them stuck in this loop
of did you mean this did you mean that
just really you know trying to provide
the best customer experience possible is
really what has helped us through this
process and then the last two kind of go
together enabling the business to get
the insights and the data they need to
deploy this at scale using it to deploy
new intents make changes on the fly when
it comes to confidence thresholds that
we use changing the kind of language
that the virtual assistant uses and that
they the customer sees when they're
communicating with a virtual assistant
is really important to us and so being
able to do that at scale is really
crucial for us
[Music]